- My question is how do I hustle
and stop being a pussy and
attack the world?
I want to be where you are.
I've got--
- What's blocking you?
- I don't know.
- Other people's POV?
- Yes.
- That's the one man.
- How do I just, I
know I can be where--
- Is it like parents?
- I don't know what it is.
- Who are the other people?
- Society, yeah its family.
- Yeah man.
Gotta have that real
talk especially tougher for
immigrants and shit like that.
Gotta look them in the
fucking face and be like
this is what I'm doing.
And like fuck you
for judging me.
And you know how hard that is?
You could go to the ground
and never be able to do it.
But if you want the
answer, that's the answer.
- That's cool.
- You know what I mean?
- Thank you man.
- You gotta get there,
and honestly man,
you just gotta get there.
Like everyday in same way
Mike with my training that
was every day in my head.
I got to fix this,
I gotta get my health right.
Gotta get my health right.
Every day you gotta say I gotta
tell my dad, I gotta tell my dad,
I gotta tell my mom,
I gotta tell my brother every day
until you finally
break and you just get it.
You find your opening
Dad blah-blah-blah.
You got to get that
poison out of the your body.
Gotta the poison
out of your body.
You know?
- Okay.
You know what the
craziest part is?
The craziest part and I've said
this enough and a couple people,
thank God, have taken me up on
it deep down you've seen the
movies that parent or that
sibling or that spouse normally
respect you more for doing it.
So you're worried about respect
and you're losing it because
they can taste the fear in your
face and then you go and do it
and what you wanted you got by
doing the actions is going to
free you up to do it.
- That's deep man.
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
- [Man] Do you
want me to take it?
- Yes, please.
You can do it brother.
Hit me up on email
it's in Crush It!
if you need my help.
Every day, every day, every day.
The same way I wake up every day
and make pretend my family died
and that's why I'm always happy
you need to pound yourself into
I gotta tell them today.
I got to go do this and the only
reason I'm not is 'cuz you're
gonna judge me and you
got to tell me that you won't.
And they tell you that they will
judge you then at least you got
it out and then you go and
then fucking prove them wrong.